- I'm gonna be doing some
relationship coaching
and matchmaking with the help of
Astrofashonista Zodiac Guru.
We're gonna find some love
based on Zodiac signs.
- Yeah, and hopefully we'll
be back for a wedding later.
(light pop music)
- My dating lifestyle is
basically nonexistent.
I came out two years ago,
and I grew up in the Midwest
and I'd had a girlfriend before but
I've never dated a guy before.
- In my dating life, I've
encountered a lot of Virgos.
It's like I'm a Virgo magnet.
- Now I wanna build an
empire with somebody.
Somebody who's compassionate,
kind, loving, crazy
but also can philosophize
about I don't know,
the ever expanding universe.
- So the daters are gonna take the
Spicy Assessment.
Which stands for self, passion, intimacy,
communication, and learning to say yes.
With this assessment I'm gonna be able to
dive in deeper into their
interpersonal development
and where we need to
strengthen so that I can
help them find the perfect match.
- And then I'm gonna look
at their natal chart,
look at their love planets,
and then make my perfect
zodiac recommendation to Spicy
and so we can find them the best match.
- I'm just gonna try to answer these
as honestly as possible.
- I have standards and ideals in my mind
about what I expect a
relationship to look like.
Uhm, yeah.
- My fear of rejection
makes it difficult for me
to provide self exposure
in a relationship.
Ooh, that is really personal.
- Sexual chemistry is important
to you in a relationship.
Strongly, strongly, strongly,
strongly, strongly agree
with that.
'Cause sex is important.
- I feel like this is almost
like a therapy session.
- During my childhood my
parents shared their opinions
and permitted me to share mine.
I mean, I feel like I'm
about to have a breakdown.
- I feel like I'm ready to date now,
'cause there were some questions here
that I had never even thought to ask.
- Based on what the daters told me,
I decided that I was gonna really take
into account what they
need personality type
that would be a good balance.
But I also wanted to
challenge them a little bit.
Miku in particular, she has a great energy
and she's passionate about life.
She said no Virgo so guess who I decided
to set her up with.
- I'm Kupah James.
I'm a Virgo and my personality is probably
described in three words,
that's raw, positive, and energy.
I'm extremely confident that
I will be that one Virgo
that changes all past
perceptions of Virgos
and sweeps her right off her feet.
- So Tamara's a double Virgo
but she has a Scorpio moon,
which means she's really intense
and not so easy to get to know.
- She has a strong sexual appetite
so we knew that a Scorpio
would be perfect for her
and Tyler is extremely beautiful
and would be able to
hold Tamara's attention.
Probably describe myself to be
fun for sure, a little bit goofy, but shy.
It's so hard finding
like a genuine person.
I just want somebody to
keep it real with me.
- [Spicy] So Ryan's a
Gemini and we thought
he could probably only do
well with another Gemini.
- But then we thought of
Curly who's actually a Virgo
and a lot of people don't
know but Virgo and Gemini
have the same sign ruler,
Mercury the communication planet.
- Curly had a lot of
relationship experience.
He's also extremely fun and charismatic.
- I'm basically just looking for someone
to join me along in my journey.
Almost like a condiment
to my burger, you know.
Something a little extra.
I'm excited to find love
but who are we kidding, I'm also excited
to find a little bit of dick, you know.
- It's up to them now to make sure that
this lasts longer than just one date.
(poppy music)
- I set up this lunch
date for me and Tamara.
We're gonna be making
some cucumber martinis
and one of my favorite desserts.
Hi.
- Hi!
And then you do that
thing where it's like,
hug or hand
but she was down to
hug so I was like, cool
'cause I'm a hugger.
Awesome, we're off to a good start.
- Hi, oh my gosh.
- Hi.
- I'm so excited.
- Hi baby how are you?
- Wow.
Oh my gosh, hi!
- Today we're gonna be painting portraits
of each other and I think that having
a little bit of wine and
a little bit of paint
will help loosen him up a little bit.
- I've never been on a date before.
- You've never been on a date before?
- [Ryann] No.
- Cheers.
- Yes, cheers, oh that was upside down.
I'm like,
I'm already awkward on a date.
- No, you're fine.
- So I'm super excited to meet Miku today.
She's my blind date and
I planned this rally cool
date for us to do.
It's gonna take place in this main studio
that I rented out just for us.
Boss!
- I'm Miku!
- Nice to meet you.
- My name is Kupah,
officially.
- Cooper?
- Kupah.
- Kupah?
- Yeah, K-U-P-A-H.
- Kupah!
Like a chupacabra.
- Like a chupacabra.
Or like King Kuppa in Mario Brothers
might be a little bit easier.
- Okay.
I was maybe a little bit intimidated
because I was like, is he
gonna kick my ass right now?
- How does that feel?
That feel heavy
but light enough?
- Yeah.
Awe, these aren't heavy.
- Alright, alright, cool.
- Did I walk into a training session
or a blind date?
I'm not really sure.
(electronic music)
- Alright, let's make a
double.
Let's get to know your
dirty laundry.
- I don't drink so I was like,
oh, man I can't partake in this.
- [Tyler] Let's make you a virgin one
honestly.
- Yeah.
Cause I'm so innocent.
- Yeah right.
- I'm trying to get your
impeccable style down.
- Oh, that's gonna be the hardest part.
I used to be really big on dating guys
with style and now I'm like, no.
- Really?
- Well I'm just kinda
like, yeah, I don't care.
Like, now I'm like, I just want somebody
with a good credit score
who can make me laugh.
(laughter)
- Now, do you like surprises?
- I love surprises!
- You do?
- I'm here right?
- Yeah, good point.
I set up a photoshoot for us.
You like taking pictures?
- I do.
- Good.
Alright, so, I'm gonna go like this right,
you're gonna come behind me
and you're gonna like lean on.
Alright, so, here we go.
Okay, so, hold on.
Oh.
(laughing)
- We started making these parfaits.
At one point she put like,
whipped cream in my mouth.
Which I thought was like,
cute.
We ain't gotta make a cake.
- All we need is the whipped cream.
- Right, right, right, right.
I feel like they were settin' us up
for somethin' else
'cause there was strawberries,
there was whipped cream,
and chocolate syrup.
Three things that lead to somethin' else.
- It's kinda like a broken heart.
- No but it's not a broken heart.
I was tryin' to make more of a like,
indent right there.
- A V, I got you.
- Yeah.
- It looks like cleavage.
I'm into that.
- I mean, look, boobs or heart.
I am okay with that.
- So, are you ready to see our paintings?
- I am, I hope you like this.
I hope I did justice.
- I think I'm gonna like mine
'cause I've never seen
a painting of myself
that I didn't like.
- One, two, three.
- Dun, dun dun dun, dun dun, dun.
I look like a 1980s Nintendo character.
- It's like, you look like a villain.
Curly responded really well
and it honestly ended up being this
really fun time.
- Oh my gosh!
Your ankles are so smooth.
He knew what he was doing.
Especially 'cause he
lifted me up in the air
and I trusted him not to kill me.
- So, my job was to
unprove whatever you
think you know about all
past Virgos
and introduce a new version of Virgo
and that would be I.
- He was a Virgo though.
What?
I did not expect that.
- I would absolutely go
on another date with Miku.
If she would have me.
Seeing as I'm a Virgo.
- I feel like I would probably like,
break his heart.
Like he seemed too sweet
and too nice and I'm like a Black Widow,
I would've destroyed him.
I need a bad motherfucker,
you know what I mean?
- The vibe was definitely fun.
Funny, exciting, intimate.
It was cool.
She's good about like, body language.
She made me feel comfortable.
We had fun.
- Yeah, so maybe I didn't find true love
but this experience has taught me to stay
more open or that I am
more open to letting
somebody ask me out, which
I mean, hey,
I'm available.
- Dating was such a risk
and it's just worth it.
I feel like no matter what
you were worried about,
just take that chance.
I'm glad that I took a risk here
and opened up to someone
and had them open up to me.
- I'm not big on going on blind dates,
so this was a little
out of my comfort zone.
But I'm really glad I did it.
It was a super adventurous date
and I had a lot of fun.
So,
I can't complain.
I mean, I'm actually
gonna hang out with him
after this so I dunno if
that tells you anything.
I don't hate Virgos.
(soft pop music)